hit me with the best face pumpkin
oh
that sounded like a hurt
it did are you bleeding
oh god
today we're checking out the most epic
face palms that's right a reddit video i
haven't done those
yeah let's go
bring it back you should start you read
it what is happening with my camera ah
[ __ ] look like a meteor flew by it's a
ghost i think i have iso on auto hold up
i can't have that the auto iso oh my
what kind of loser you don't manual it
up
too though even though my color is
always off now because we record it at
night for me oh
blaze
it's too dark but i can't i don't want
to i don't want to go up again just turn
it all the way up like you did that one
time
come home to newly laid concrete
driveway i did not order a concrete
driveway nor any type of driveway the
person that laid it came back to see if
i was happy with the job and i realized
it was a wrong address now i got a free
concrete driveway how is that a face
bomb that's the face wind let's go
concrete driveway that actually looks
good he did a good job my eyes always
make god damn
how is your iso messed up i don't
understand like what have you changed
why have you need to change anything i
use it as a photo camera as well okay
that's no no no you're wrong all right
you got to get two cameras okay one sits
at the desk it never moves so you never
have to deal with any of these problems
all right all right sorry i'm not rich
okay
you can just use your phone you know
freaking phones on cameras or cameras on
phones again speak you got me so
bothered i'm sorry i like to take your
next photos okay and i like that camera
so i will use it
but i bought a clip in thing so i can
take it off and on easily but yes
sometimes i forget to change back to
settings i'm sorry ken
why are we fighting you don't have to
cover for marzia okay i know that she's
like get your good camera no no no she
prefers her camera i want to take it
with my camera because i know how to use
that one does margie tell you that you
take horrible pictures because mary
tells me that i take hardware
well
you probably do take f hover before this
excuse me i take horrible photos and i
still get told i take bad pictures so
how do you feel
it's really encouraging when you're
trying your best at something and then
it's like
this is trash
yeah you get the angle you're like
getting down like yeah this could be
real good
turn the camera
that's the big face palm right there
she's like oh why are you so bad at this
with his handmade keychains that go for
five dollars each this eight-year-old
boy raised four thousand fifteen to
erase the lunch dab of students from his
school and six others eight-year-old
does months of manual labor so his
friends who her children can afford to
eat without going into debt yeah all
right good is that all it takes for
people to stop complaining about poor
kids being hungry great let's make more
girls my family was real poor i got to
eat for free you know i just i gave them
like my number i have a lunch number
they have to pay for nothing i said what
wait sorry i'm
say that again you what so all they
gotta do is just tell the school that
they're poor and they can eat for free
that's easy easy see i have a privilege
kid problem which is way worse than when
you had to go through ken i went to a
fancy school and all my rich friends
were like we look at the menu of the
food and they're like
i don't want to eat that let's go and go
to a restaurant and me being poor and
not having money at the privilege school
i was like you were allowed to leave the
school together yes yes yes and people
did it all the time and i'm like i don't
can't really afford this but i also
don't want to sit i also don't want to
sit alone i also don't want to sit alone
in the cafeteria like a loser
my school had a razor wire around the
fence so you couldn't escape
we were able to leave our school in like
super early grade i don't know why it
was weird for me too i was like damn we
can just guys we could
just leave
that's crazy bro this is not face palm i
want a face pump oh what about this
imagine hating england imagine hating
england there's no country in the world
more beautiful oh well some would
disagree but okay okay i already see a
problem with this there's a blue sky in
two of these images
that does not happen well the guy down
here at the bottom says i feel like when
people say i hate england they're not
referring to the plants and cows
[Laughter]
yeah but the cows kill people okay
remember
you always tell me that oh you gotta
google okay show me the
show with another 80 people 80 people
never people don't talk about it
trampolining is a serious issue okay and
there's nothing to joke about
look at look at the cows that's sitting
there waiting for the next victim this
guy was attacked by a cow was he yeah
looks like he just scratched the
mosquito bite too hard what the heck
hey i'll show chat here
brighton seafront scaffolding
that's beautiful actually scaffolding
scaffolding
it's all scaffolding everywhere you
can't even enjoy the that's that gear
he's cute you can't even enjoy anything
because all the buildings are like 6 000
years old and always
dying
whenever whenever you flew us in for
your wedding and we went and walked
around and saw everything we went to see
like big ben and everything it was a
scaffolding
the [ __ ] capital league crazy
this definitely everywhere is so loud
they're doing it neighbors here they
were like one month ago
stop it with a [ __ ] scaffolding
please
it takes forever to put up you know they
gotta leave it there they gotta leave it
and they never do anything one dude sits
there like oh yeah
scrape some brick a little bit yeah if i
if i was leader england which i will be
one day mark my word i will say hey you
put up scaffolding you got x amount of
time to do your [ __ ] job and then
it's got to go it's got to go you can't
just keep make it there or or and if you
extend that period you get a tax i don't
give a [ __ ] i hate taxes but i hate
scaffolding more i feel like people have
to do like disneyland you will have to
do like disneyland and make a pretty
image in the front so i don't have to
see your stupid stuff
like just put a picture over it like
it's true roll it out yes that's bad
i feel like this is like barrels all
over again it's not barrels anymore it's
scaffolding
i told my parents about it scaffolding
what is that they don't even know
they don't even know i don't have it in
in sweden it doesn't exist no we
eradicated the problem the promised land
it's not like we don't have any
buildings in sweden we're old to england
stopping
that's a major face problem right there
anyway moving on
we looked at about two of them so far
kim oh my god is every one of these
political what politics
protests
all right here we go home inspection yes
all right let's go
[Applause]
quality beautiful transition wow they
did it so well
i would bet
i bet you that shakes
every toilet seat shakes
oh okay it was a whole toilet
looking towel rack
but they just wow good job
bro this looks like i did it
why they put silicon in there to fill
the gap
what they could have just put in like a
white silicone right would look decent
they didn't even fill the gap they could
just like screw to the wall like it's
supposed to be on there i don't know all
right
all right i like it good looking shower
stall but i don't think i've ever seen
that
cheese
wow personal favorites whenever they
installed part of the
nice crack
oh they didn't take out the tape okay
unless this is actually the exterior of
the home
we can literally see behind the brick
what is that
vapor barrier
we have a giant void all the way up
where the stone veneer meets the brick
wait i don't get that one what was that
like the the gap that he's talking about
between the brick oh they're not
attached is that it okay or the stone
veneers this is quality man
diy
american houses looking porch
nice warped
yeah what the hell
con screws you can just use putty to
attach a spigot to the exterior
nice looks like the sight superintendent
just decided to allow the guys to throw
their trash under the deck
you should also not use a wood pallet to
support a water heater oh my god
they keep doing that
my god and we have a damaged window and
instead of actually just replacing nice
trim nice i just use caulk
yeah i don't know if you can see it from
here but the hardwood and tile in this
area are not perfectly flush it's about
a half inch above the hardwood
and on the sides and the corners it's
about a quarter of an inch
coming into the garage as far as the
handrail is concerned
it's also sticking out it's really
awkward my favorite
part they didn't even bother connecting
the motor
[Laughter]
500 000 half a million wow half a
million congratulations holy crap i feel
like this is way more common than
just this this is not just like a
one-time thing
really yeah
well i mean i don't know it's it's new
to me but okay wait maybe this is a
brand new house but like
issues seems to appear so quickly on
like newly built houses the only new
houses i've ever like really dealt with
like growing up is like the houses that
my dad built or like oversaw and he was
like cut through with like people
messing up he was like fire everybody
and he could then he complains about
never having any help
so that's that's that's nuts that
someone built an entire house and that
has that many problems i i uh okay rich
people complaining rich people complain
i don't care i also have problems thank
you all right listen i bought the house
and i as part of the deal i asked okay
install the new game because that one is
crappy and i want it to be electric
they're like fine we'll do that it's
been in repair since we got it like it's
never even worked
and then i asked them like okay this is
not okay you need to send the guy who
did it back they're like yeah we're
trying to reach them but we just can't
like no they don't work
look are you kidding me
i think i think she's mad at me because
their ch son or someone wanted like a
free signature or some [ __ ] and i forgot
about it
i've forgotten about it yeah but then i
actually got like a big gift to them and
i wrote them like i have it didn't reply
well they must not really want it to
begin with them you know what they need
to teach you in school is that
people are emotional [ __ ] and
they will not do their job like babies
how housing is annoying anyway because
once they sell it to you and it's signed
over yeah they're like
not in japan whatever my house in japan
they're like oh we fixed everything
five years five years forever we come
the problem fix it japan pass
too bad you'll never get there exactly
my five years is running low
do it
and then when you do get there they'll
be scaffolding outside
to be fair they did an expectation well
i they didn't even tell me about it
they're like yeah they set it up with
the whatever they did it and they fixed
a bunch of problems and i'm like that's
amazing i love you i have problems when
no one's living in it that was uh one of
the
wells
had broken outside my house they had a
crack in it that was it they're like
we'll fix this for you being nice yeah
very nice you're anything good on this
entire reddit no did you just do like
top of all time no this year that was a
terrible year yeah it's been a bad year
face palm is making me face bum i think
it's hidden it's not actually face palm
it's facebook because this is like this
facebook post this is some facebook post
yeah you're right yeah yo only in miami
an advertisement at the beach
telling you how to buy dunkin donuts
i love that i don't have a problem with
that
buy food
freaking america the problem is if they
make noises that then we got a problem
oh yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
is your ad still in canada or whatever
for g fuel yeah they need to put that on
the boat yeah how much did that boat
cost come on oh i think i heard i've
heard about this he didn't open the door
he wanted someone to open the door for
him
[Laughter]
what a loser
what do you think it's mark zuckerberg
what do you think
open a freaking door dude
let's be the devil's advocate for mark
zuckerberg here how do you defend this
maybe he told him i strain my wrist
i can't open my door he saw that video
with like the giant spotter crawls out
from under the door handle and he's like
i'm mark zuckerberg a lot of people are
depending on me being healthy so
obviously i can't put myself at risk
i just got my nails done i ain't
touching it
okay that one that one works my
president donald trump lives here
it's not the white house do people not
know that
even i knew that what is that called the
lincoln center or something
i actually don't even remember i don't
know what it's called i just know it's
not the white house
i don't live in america anymore so you
know whatever i forgot everything all
the knowledge just draining out over
here
now you think i'm shrimping bobby mate
it's all you thinking so you talk about
man they don't even say put shrimp on
the barbie because they eat prawns yes
they do they don't eat shrimp they eat
culture that's how you speak in
australia
i have to listen to everyone i'm going
through your swedish
all right you're it's called shrimp okay
because i say it listen
and i'm sorry for being so offensive
that i went sweet of chef on you
sorry i interrupted you what were you
saying no i was i was apologizing that i
went sweet of chef when you back there
cause i remember it was like eight years
ago
i was like so
have you ever seen sesame street and
you're like
yeah
do you know about the swedish chef yeah
i know about him it's
racist my bad dude oh man does anybody
else make that joke to you everyone
everyone how dare they uh banasa uses
the
what about the metric system but
america's been to the moon
oh that's so cool congrats
what was that like uh 40 years ago about
50 years ago i don't even know it was
longer than that
around 50 years ago congrats i also my
achievement from 50 years ago i always
brag about this well
i have a on my phone my calculator it
has a conversion thing for me and i use
it all the time because i'm like yeah i
need a i need a piece of wood i need
like a two by four two inches by four
inches and uh
millimeters or something like that i
don't know it's crazy man i gotta say
when in construction terms that whatever
america uses makes more sense like you
don't need centimeters it's just
annoying you never get it right anyway
it's like yeah that's all that's 18 feet
and 1 4 inches or yeah 1 16 you know all
that the problem is really uk that uses
everything they got all of it they just
like oh so uh a stone okay fahrenheit i
will never understand that it's just
illegal
fahrenheit yeah well
32 degrees is you know anything below
that's freezing and uh i don't know
boiling's 200 and something 212 or
something like that
but then celsius is like below zero is
freezing above 100 is boiling it's like
wow that's easy okay now i got to set my
air conditioner on the wall like 22
degrees celsius or something and i don't
know i'll get confused that's when i get
my my little phone out mm-hmm
so you're like celsius right i do
because it makes more sense it makes
more sense
that's interesting did you know
do you know who invented celsius ken
sweden [ __ ]
sweden invented pewdiepie they've hit
celsius they invented it
i don't know it's zip zipper burst
zipper branch
they when they've been ranch uh well the
the adjustable wrench sorry oh ranch
yeah not ranged
oh my god it rains
i'm going to sweden
what the [ __ ] why is it all political
what happened to reddit the facepalm was
that entire freaking
reddit subreddit oh my god oh my god
okay wait kid destroys printer for tick
tock in front of his parents
[Music]
stop
man
i didn't do it
it wasn't me
this seems like tick tock yeah
his parents are pretty young i thought
it was his brother oh yeah yeah what do
you do when your kids get tick tock and
they start doing this game
oh god what are my kids going to do when
they get older uh they'll be great
because they have great parents
i mean their dad's the greatest youtuber
of all time obviously so
they got big shoes to fill
yeah what do they get oh no
to be fair printers are pretty cheap so
incorporates the ink that really costs
money so
i think this is a social commentary
really more than anything the one time
of year that you need to print something
out right one time a year the whole
reason you bought the printer
doesn't work yeah and you got to spend
80 bucks to get another freaking it
should be illegal why don't everyone fix
this it's the same with light bulbs did
you know they all went together and made
it so that light bulbs are [ __ ] they
sold lightbulb breaking i feel like a
lot of technology like that i feel like
the internet's like that the internet
can be great but it's like you know
we'll just if we keep the
we keep it low we have to charge it more
for like average speeds
is that internet we're getting censored
right never having to pay for texts
can't hear you you can't hear me now i
hear you do you remember how to pay for
text messages what the [ __ ] was that all
about
exactly
yes oh yeah and you gotta pay for data
now with your internet in some place i
don't know it's like they just charge
for what they're able to but then
eventually someone goes why are we
charging for that let's get away for
free and then everything changes yes
yeah let's do that with the ink please
do you know it costs more than human
blood i don't know if that's true but i
heard that i heard that ink for the
print that cost more than human play i'm
going to start using human blood for my
printer i guess you might as well what
is so hard i might have been
all right feel that
what do we do i mean we've got like 15
minutes of a video so far oh
dang you hear that
what was that ken
or it must be the
it must be the printer gods they're
angry
lightning striking out that was so loud
what the [ __ ] what's up dude holy crap
there's a storm outside really survive
no but what is happening it's raining
really hard that was so loud
made me jump
i got this censored like a compressed
version of it it sounded weird oh my
internet's probably crapping out because
the ain't gods
i'm scared you have to respect other
people's opinions their opinion yeah
that
seems about right
it took me a second because i'm here i'm
terrible at math but uh it's literally
six it's six y'all smoking it's
literally six but okay it's six y'all
don't understand how ex exponents work
i feel like i'm being gaslit what the
[ __ ] it's not six it's nine
is it though
oh my god
yeah it's basically three times three
it's three squared bro yeah i mean it's
just it's 32 obviously someone just they
ran
they messed up the font and
norway is the happiest country in the
world no that's a face palm oh cringe
you know i keep up with stocks right
yeah and uh
you know
opera right
norway mm-hmm yeah and i think
when the video came out of you talking
about that you know you realize that
they make it you made it their stock
went down
that is not correlated there's no way
you you you were crashing the market
over there
if you notice i don't know people at
home probably don't notice that we're
using like firefox or something right
now
[Laughter]
good
nor
bad cop no donut don't die yet
vehicle
1039-1039 jso
36 miles per hour
and a 15 mile per hour zone 15 miles per
hour that's way too slow
i don't care if they're
i don't care if there's a
children
oh my here we go
i ain't driving 15 for anyone i i got
places to go shoot if this was you
driving right now you'd be going you
know who knows how fast and you'd see
the family parking and you just have to
like just
slot sideways into it
flipping the birds they'll be like oh my
god this pewdiepie could have a picture
he's like no
you throw them dog food or whatever it
is
oh my god i'm joking by the way
back up
36 miles per hour in a 15 mile per hour
zone
he did actually i saw that he did
actually
i don't want to
cause an accident
i'm in i'm on the sidewalk dude
you're busted man
[Laughter]
you get off the road
like he didn't pause he did he didn't
slow down right before
look
slowed right there it glitched so i
guess he slept
he
slowed down after he passed the guy yeah
he didn't see that doing hey yeah he did
right
this is the karen all right now the tick
tock here we go
oh here she comes
you did that to the front of my [ __ ]
car oh yeah
that's my new car usually
[Music]
[Laughter]
remember what happened remember what
happened yeah this was your call
you ran into me
with the back of your car
oh my god
oh yeah
okay
that's cool uh probably move the car
from thing and i'll call the cops for
you
yeah she just left it in the middle of
the road too nice one
how are these people made there's so
many of them in america all right here
we go
is that the gas station oh there we go
oh he has a nice car too
[Music]
how could you do that to the front of my
vehicle
remember when you did that
oh my god
[Music]
i need a dash cam just for people like
this i feel like it's like
self-incriminating evidence if you get a
dash cam
why
but i don't even make me tell stories
about driving again okay my driving
perfect i'm super safe the dash cam
would just be you yelling at people
because i wanted them to do better ken i
i asked jack what he thought of my
driving and he said
you're decent
does jack even have a driver's license
i was like decent
that's it
can he even drive i don't know i don't
think so
i think he can obviously he knows what
he's talking about right oh he doesn't
like to drive yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
probably scarred after
running around you never want to
all right i'm surprised
honestly
i'm an excellent driver okay i've been
in one accident and in retrospect it
wasn't my phone
what did they mess up the front of your
car by you rear-ending him i may yeah
yeah yeah
all right
she came up way too fast dude she was
way too fast but i totally got something
we came way too fast i did a right turn
i look left and i look right and i look
left again i drive out she
like hits the front of my car she hit
the front of my car literally like this
poor woman here in this video that we
just saw right because there was a hill
and i you know come fast her fault she
should not be going that fast
how could she how dare she not know who
you are oh my god
anyway face palm
uh check out subscribe more videos epic
hit the bell button epic
and uh check out ken epic
facebook